voilà c'est mon frère voilà c'est mon
frère
cela s'entend à tous les deux voilà
c'est énorme à siècle à 2 il ya une
super atmosphère dans ce restaurant cccc
nulle part ailleurs
voilà vivre nos
[Musique]
parfois c'est douloureux
oui c'est long mais on va un peu on a
choisi jean-pierre bon alors c'est
combien au total on est entre 100 et 120
donc on est 120 minimum peut-être 122
122 224 donc j'ai su que tu connais un
peu le principe on va t'envoyer plein de
petites choses différentes au fur et à
mesure où les gens arrivent très bien
que des microplaques fait d'apicius voir
ont fait griller une petite saint
jacques par une sage a enfin bref mon
ami m'a fait d un peu les a mis les
petits plats dans les grands pour vous
tout est moderne tout en étant
naturel et puis après ce qu'on mange
aussi parce que
très grand chef vraiment d
toutes les fins c'est pas ostentatoire
cuisine que j'aime
[Applaudissements]
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les réclamations et un tourteau
attention sanchiz coustilles entre le
mois d'août et la nage
je crois qu'un palace est devenu avant
tout un endroit où les chefs se réfugie
c'est vrai que on a la chance d'être
supportés par par les chambres de portée
par le par l'outil travail en lui-même
aujourd'hui les restaurants se trouve
toile et les plus étoilés se trouve au
sein des hôtels pour une raison de
moyens évident allez on y va vous avez
les produits de la chasse au lièvre à la
royale le perdreau rôti s'est préparée a
crû très fameux également la truffe
blanche
notre blanche d'alba qui cela qu'ils se
serrent sur les coquilles saint jacques
par exemple il avait également un très
joli entrecôte que nous vient de pas
vierge et dans les cas de jean zay à
madrid
donc voilà les gros spécialité du choc
entre nous pour l'auteur
le briefing ce soir quarante deux
couvertures très stable donc bien
maximiser nous avons dans nos murs
mettra avouent leur qui est de retour
j'aimerais qu'on pressent encore deux
ananas comme il ya quinze jours jusqu à
peu près mercredi eric d'accord dont
vous allez au bar vouloir demander qui
prépare les crs
[Musique]
tout doit être absolument parfait dans
la salle on doit avoir une vue
d'ensemble agréable au regard les tables
doivent toutes être alignés parfaitement
chaque chose à sa place là vous le voyez
la fleur est à droite le photophores est
à gauche
le sel et poivre est au centre de la
table on a une harmonie parfaite sur les
tables et qui est la même vraiment
partout c'est à dire qu'à l'oeil
y'a rien n'y a rien qui cloche il est
clair que quand les personnes passent se
sont assis les coûts 500 crasé donc ont
regonflé les coussins voyez c'est les
ampoules également sa part est ça paraît
bête mais quatre lustres on doit veiller
à ce que les ampoules ne soit pas
griller donc on regarde tous
[Musique]
ce
alors les assiettes ont une
particularité
durant le déjeuner ou durant le dîner on
fait le repas avec ce côté de l'assiette
c'est à dire que c'est une truffe qui a
été grossie un certain nombre de fois
vous pouvez remarquer également la
sienne dans face elle est différente
parce que chaque truffe également une
différente au moment du sucré il ya un
changement de décor pour un changement
de saveurs donc on se retourne en pivote
et on change
l'assiette en fait et c'est le plafond
c'est une partie du plafond ça c'est un
souhait de monsieur alléno c'est un clin
d'oeil en fait à l'enfance quand il
était notamment chez sa grand mère à la
campagne
il est obligé de terminer son assiette
sa grand mère lui disait une gamine pas
ton assiette tu n'auras pas de dessert
parce qu'il retournait l'assiette on
faisait beaucoup ça dans les campagnes
pour manger le dessert dessus un peu le
bazar c'est bien un
j'aime beaucoup
on a ici des gens qui ont fait des
milliers de kilomètres pour venir goûter
notre cuisine comme ça ça vaut le voyage
et il faut que ça vaille le voyage parce
que sinon c'est une catastrophe quoi
[Musique]
alors là on est sonné place du marché on
est un peu au centre de ce village
le grand restaurant là bas avec l'hôtel
cinq étoiles
là bas il ya le grand parc avec le spa
là l'ancienne auberge la boulangerie on
occupe un quartier du village c'est
presque un village dans le village il y
avait une forme d'adversité les gens
comprenaient pas bien c'était j'ai
monisme malsain où on voulait tout
acheter george burgess et où ils
achètent tous et pour lens limite prix
on a fixé nos limites la licorne qui
sont en haut là c'est les limites du
village
on les retrouve plus loin ou quatre
coins du village ça veut pas dire qu'il
ya un péage 1
[Musique]
alors cette maison et c'est n'est plus
vieilles maisons étoilées puisque ma
grand mère a eu la première étoile en
1929 elle ajouté très vite la deuxième
étoile en 1931 1981 donc un demi siècle
le ballet va commencer
et à peu près 150
le signal
prestigieuse carole bouquet son
anniversaire à l'âge et kad merad qui
vient qui vient c'est souvent quand il
fait étape ici en route vers marseille
geslin dans les grenouilles cherves
aznavour ici oui voilà halte
incontournable
une de mes meilleures tables voilà romy
schneider qui est venu j'ai eu un
échange avec elle m'a beaucoup parlé de
sa mère de laurent gerra qui est mon
voisin laurent c'est la star de la
bresse ici parce que il habitait vonnas
et sa maman travailler ici dans le
restaurant jules orange les connu il a
le même âge que fred confie ce que
frédéric mon fils il était toujours mes
patins dans les coulisses à faire des
bêtises quand il était très jeune
1 4 kilomètre d'ici où il ya la sortie
d'autoroute sur l'a40 de certains
esprits malveillants disent que c'est la
sortie georges blanc parce que l'on j'ai
été chef de file d'une intervention pour
que cette sortie s'ouvre alors que
l'autoroute était terminée depuis
quelques années déjà
là la sortie nous nous met à quatre
minutes du restaurant on s'est fait un
peu chambrer à nous à dire le foot il
peut y avoir une sortie d'autoroute le
début on engagé cette action tous les
soutiens que j'avais tout le monde me
disait mais dors je sais bien que j'ai
plein d'idées mais tu crois vraiment au
père noël il doit faire une sortie je
sais combien ça coûte et en fait elle
est là la sortie depuis 20 ans je pense
que ça fait un peu partie de la magie du
lieu qu'on puisse venir dans cet endroit
arrivé en hélicoptère voilà j'ai le
souvenir de tom cruise qui étaient
restées là quelques jours pendant son
voyage de noces avec nicole kidman et
qui était reparti en hélicoptère
j'avais passé beaucoup de temps avec lui
on est allé faire des balades dans le
mâconnais beaujolais
on a fait quelques casse croûte
sympathique au bord de saône et je me
souviens qu'ils étaient repartir et on
avait eu beaucoup de mal à loger dans
l'hélicoptère tous les cadeaux qu'il
avait acheté la boutique antoine ça va
ça va ça va mais vous voilà pour les
chiffres
c'est ça vous êtes sous le thème des
biens de jamais sortir regardez donc on
est dans la même c'est à dire la même
base que les mois et c'est ce qui est en
jaune
voilà c'est fait ça c'est le chiffre
global on a encore en cumulé une
progression de 8%
un peu plus de 8 22% là et demi un mois
ça fait plus de plus 15% rapport ça
tient quoi cette progression et
l'ouverture du l'hôtel en face
ici on est en jaune
[Musique]
nos pâtisseries ont fait le pain est
alors pour les restaurants et aussi pour
les gens du village qui viennent ici
je pense quand même qu'ici à l'ancienne
auberge
on a un meilleur résultat financier que
aux trois étoiles il consomme beaucoup
de main d'oeuvre beaucoup de choses
onéreuse au niveau des produits que
c'est un film cuisine plus simple ici
toujours élaborés avec des produits
frais de qualité quand même
[Musique]
donnez moi une petite poêle
s'il vous plaît tout le monde en place
laetitia avec la cuisse la cuisson
tonton poisson il était parfait la
cuisson du poisson il était parfait ne
peux pas c'est peut-être là quand je te
le dis voilà
et c'était très bon c'est très mijoter
il suffit que ce soit juste un petit peu
plus brillants tu t'organises mieux au
niveau de ton endroit et tout ça ça doit
disparaître tu me mets un bain marie
avec toutes les sauces bien rangée ici
d'accord ça ça doit disparaître ça doit
disparaître ici tu dois avoir un je
voulais quelque chose de concret pour
faire plaisir aux gens et être vraiment
les choses de terre à terre et non pas
dans le truck intellectuelle où on a
toujours un doute dans le droit c'est
tout le temps incertain et je voulais
pas être danseur dans les papiers
travaillent dans un bureau
je prouverai la lazio terrain dans le
vif de l'action
[Musique]
et je rêve ou semanya pénalement oui
d'annoncé pour valeureux jeunes gens
tous et à la paix que j'aime voir ça on
va mettre la nature d'accord allez et
parce que sin le nappage d'hommes bas il
faut pas pu se passer le pied sans
toucher voyez on va envoyer s'il vous
plaît on va envoyer la table 8 dans la 8
elle était réclamée bien avant alors on
envoie l'a8 d'abord voilà ça c'est pour
le salon ça c'est pour la 8
alors ensuite qu'est ce qu'on a six
villes ont bien rigolé de riscle afrique
5 séries 9 10 nantes ap addis de
réclamer aux réclames et on a un et 1,2
un riz avec un dès maintenant j'avais
déjà vu et 15 aides mais avec un déjà
vous avez vous alors donc 1 1 2 non 1 1
2 1 2 1 1 1 2 1
alors s'il te plaît les rideaux après il
y en a 1 1 2 et 1
c'est un peu chaud mais c'est un peu
c'est un peu pas dit qu'un cuisine mais
non mais ça va aller on va récent mais
adrien comment tu peux envoyer ça c'est
bleu des trois capables de voir que la
viande à l'époque 8 est levé tous les
filets de caille effacer les un petit
coup à la halle à poil juste pour les
saisir voyez suisse qui est un pote le
sabbat sadc désorganise toute la cuisine
toute sa cuisine parce que la deuxième
entrée elle va attendre lui il est pas
prêt donc automatiquement s'attendre là
à presse avait dit ça va décaler tous
les tables là je peux vous dire c'est un
service qui est merdique
attention de pas trop réduire la sauce
au hockey les deux gaillards cuir là ok
et civile tu suisse te plaît les deux
cas et que je viens de recueillir là et
on peut pas attendre une demi-heure pour
une entrée sont pas possibles
non ça va
j'ai pris ma sarcophage de kayes
c'est bien lui ah oui c'était excellent
par des contres très bon d'ailleurs j'ai
fini mon assiette
mais ceci dit je vous en veux pas du
d'autres moments où le départ tant qu'on
a de mettre les points sur les i lé se
dire qu'il faut dire quand même en en
priorité c'est que déjà quand on est on
a commencé nous a quand je suis venu en
cuisine à 12h30 déjà tout le monde
n'était pas là c'est à dire que quand on
a commencé à réclamer les premiers amuse
bouche qui apprennent en place à votre
poste ceci est inadmissible
donc à partir de ce moment là il ya
panique on a du mal à se mettre en place
et on n'est pas organisé donc quand même
quand on n'est pas organisée qu'est ce
qui se passait bien c'est un
enchaînement de petites bêtises qui
viennent les années les unes après les
autres ont l'impression qu'aujourd'hui
on s'était donné le mot pour que on
envoie tout cru quoi j'ai fais
entièrement confiance à adrien comme je
fais d'habitude pascal rien quand même
c'est quelqu'un en qui j'ai entièrement
confiance et je me suis fait avoir parce
que je pensais que les cas elle allait
être prêtes et les années de suite
voilà donc adrien comme les aussi un
problème appelé à l'aide
appeler à l'aide d'accord ben je suis
désolé pour avoir un peu milliards dans
sa vie normale je sais pas grand chose à
dire
[Musique]
on s'est dit bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le matin c'est la science bisous et
toutes les filles c'est obligatoire
c'est pas le droit de cuissage mais
c'est obligatoire et la voilà là le
matin le matin c'est en dix ans barbe
mais elle supporter de la retenir elle
est folle de moi
[Musique]
je suis arrivé à l'époque nous arriver
par la rue après noël
et c'est là où je me suis dit je suis
revenu j'avais des dix sans doute une
lumière différente dans les lieux
c'était noël equal des choses qui
scintillait et puis tout de suite
[Musique]
les faits
paris
deux journées
[Musique]
semaines dans un petit coin personne
personne me casse les pieds personne va
le voir et le bar n'est pas du tout
prévu pour ça mais c'est comme ça donc
on lui dresse une petite table là bas
près de la fenêtre ou huzhou de côté il
s'installe à deux ils discutent ils les
voient là alors il est avec eux ou des
acteurs ou des dés d'autres cinéastes
pas des gens et qu'il a dû parler quoi
visiter la caverne d'ali baba
alors on arrive on arrive dans sa crosse
à on était descendu dans cette dans cet
univers avec madonna et elle tombe sur
un endroit où on avait rangé les l'homme
la conseillante elle laissait son vin
préféré elle dit à l'udc en demies
français ou au luc a qu'un c'est rld à
la mlac enseignante locaux loués à la
conseillante ici on a goûté les
conseillante avec madonna l'a4 comme ça
et après ils ont continué avec avec elle
la conseillante là bas un set ça tombait
par terre
alors il ya des choses à te
[Musique]
calais
en principe pourrait faire crise assez
attention qu'ils soient pas les
saint-jacques l'après cru pour lui qui
est sans doute la bloquer deux êtres
humains monsieur loyal le lièvre à la
royale
annoncé comme le mettre là on attend
[Musique]
reçus shimon peres
bon il est bloqué la rue services de
sécurité dans tous les coins
y'avait j'ai pas coin 80 policiers plus
ou moins discrets plus ou moins armé
pour afficher un bazar terrible tout
autour qu'on ait un problème comme nos
voisins qu'on a renvoyé voir la
maréchaussée et là il s'est fait
renvoyer vertement dans les êtres parlée
par les gens des services de sécurité
donc s'ils n'étaient pas contents c'est
pareil de qui lui ont demandé ses
papiers etc
tout compte fait s'est retrouvé très
d'enquiquiner en voulant jouer les gros
bras
je suis fan d'abord de la cuisine je
suis fan des grands chefs et je suis fan
de la cuisine de monsieur vigato et puis
dès son chef le soin de faire ces belles
recettes dans les restaurants parce que
présentée comme ça je suis désolé mais
chez moi j'arriverais porte
on attend ça je veux pas on enlève les
couverts on met juste les cèpes
c'est pas une forêt c'est un petit bois
[Musique]
m
on n'arrive pas à ça mais on a une carte
il n'y a pas énormément de choix ce qui
est aussi un signe un gage de qualité
parce que quand vous avez les cartes à
rallonge il faut vous dire que rien ne
peut être frais puisque peut pas acheter
suffisamment en quantité pour que tout
le monde soit servi
de tous donc là on a six entrées 5
places et quatre défaites
c'est un très très bon écrit bonjour
vous nous dites que vous avez dans le
menu du déjeuner vous avez une entrée du
jour arrive alors là encore il est jeune
il est très gentil il est très simple
qui voit le trou noir il dit mais sa
nièce notre mémoire ça revient tout de
suite et ça c'est bien
on n'a pas envie d'avoir des mots
filiales implantées à coacher les murs
comment dépasser les bistrots miel et
moutarde atteint qui vient de celles et
ceux qui de queiroz à température
n'était ce pas elle même fut un très
beau me suis régalé alors le quasi à la
cuisson
non chez quels que soient les mérites et
un petit peu plus d'assaisonnement vous
regardez là vous êtes sur z sur des
productions haut de gamme mais j'ai
besoin d'être dans un lieu
voilà où ça joue moi je sens la
créativité plus là j'ai senti la
créativité dans l'assiette du chef les
restent un peu sur la fin
mais si vous voulez je suis pas persuadé
d'avoir envie de revenir pour dépasser
le sang de veau il reste un peu sur la
fin pour solidaires
[Musique]
on perd tout de suite là le four machin
tout ça là d'accord tu allumes la
conçois pas en garder pour les selles
d'agneau un toit c'est que tu as
commencé toi tu commences à se maquiller
les croustillants de boudin alors vas-y
commence à ce lac et toi tu allez vous
changer là un mois jouera les huîtres un
tas des plateaux la pouvoir de
présentation pour les 8 ou ba1
[Musique]
essayez de vous organiser pour voir
comment vous envoyer ta prévu de mettre
une truffe l'ac ajaccio 1 1 peut trouver
saint jacques rue les à laveyron un
travail proprement une pension de
seconde je vous présente le chef peuvent
qui nous fait manger ce soir ça me peine
notre étoile du nord le meilleur
[Applaudissements]
samet lors de l'e sata
georges au bon service serait déjà avec
une coupe de champagne à l'avocat nous
reste encore tu as encore un bon 21 plat
envoyé tu vois donc mais comme ça se
passe bien je vais les laisser sa guest
à balai ou quoi enfin jusqu'au bout
ouais mais tout ce que dame nous
abstenir juin c'est important c'est le
mariage à lui
[Musique]
les mecs peuvent pas s'empêcher un gars
qui pouvaient rentrer dans la soirée que
la pièce un grosse caisse de merde là
c'est incroyable talent son prêche à la
nuque
j'ai fait tellement mou et comme j'ai
pas pu faire autre chose c'est pas une
vocation qu'aurait omis voulait faire
quelques pas créé beaucoup de mecs en se
levant le matin disait on va faire
cuisiner eux c'est comme tout cas c'est
comme une belle femme ça tombe amoureux
[Musique]
cet effet
moi j'ai plus de traces mais j'ai monté
des coups quand même et puis son cas
n'est pas ça revenait pas les recueillir
pakula table tel un quart d'heure de
retard dont tu te les traiter une
deuxième phase
ta première bien faire les choses tout
de suite alors émis c'était tellement
bon smic ils ont tous mangé et amusants
ils n'ont pas touché
c'est bien tu as tellement c'est bien
mon jus pour le personnel qui n'ont rien
à manger
c'est bien tu as mis ton coeur je
m'attends à un restaurant je pars à mon
jeu comme ça
bravo
[Musique]
enfin la truffe blanche non non diaw cha
je vais prendre trois bons atteint 4,9
je peux je peux payer dimanche
1 combien tu n'y as combien je te dois
et j'ai oublié mon argent alors ça fait
un peu gratteur 1 on marque c'est un
sport national aussi dans le temps non
c'est vrai que bon parfois il est un peu
extravagante donc bon voilà mais dans la
mesure où le connais un petit peu soit
on accepte être qu'il ait son âme
prétendent pas à quoi mais bon je veux
dire il a un caractère tellement il est
tellement généreux qu'après on
on accepte tel qu'il est on aime tel
qu'il est j'ai pas le profil pour
travailler dans un palace parce que tu
vas bien
aujourd'hui la clientèle de palace à moi
j'adore aller homogène dans les palaces
j'adore les palaces même et je veux dire
moi j'ai pas le profil d'un palace est
bidon si michelin hong yong jo il faut
compléter cheveux waouh met une belle
cravate toi pas pour approuver si je le
redit récemment tu as fait pour que tu
veux pourquoi tu pourquoi tu veux quand
tu veux qu'on change et c'est bien
d'avoir une identité non non
[Musique]
plutôt oui on mettra les clashs et on
finira par les doors dont des clients
qui sont venus hier qui ont écouté la
section musicale ce exceptionnel se
retrouver dans un lieu étoiles exercer
entend de la musique mais vraiment c'est
génial c'est merveilleux
après c'est vrai qu'on peut pas toucher
toute la clientèle qui appelle des
petits vieux du dimanche midi
on s'adapte aussi on va passer plus du
brassens du brel enfin ces choses là
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un d'assez déroutant au
début quand on connaît pas qu'on arrive
d'abord l'établissement
on s'attend pas à voir ce genre de
personne ça que ça peut paraître un peu
bizarre et les gens savent pas vraiment
à quoi s'attendre on a même du mal à
imaginer que ce soit le chef c'est pas
difficile il suffit de se laisser
pousser les cheveux pour se laver et
puis dans sa forme dans sa démarche et
donc son esprit il est singulier unique
quoi et c'est un très beau nage
retrouver ici manger de découvrir le re
découvrir à chaque fois sous l'eau
m
[Musique]
chapiteau du ministre il a été un peu
dur sans nom est sur une pente raide
trois longues en italien français
anglais et derrière on avise auto on a
quatre risotto on a les wagons lits il y
en a les artichauts
l'idée le cder s'il apporte un peu de
savoir-faire plutôt orienté son cuisine
est très italienne et militaria c'est à
dire que toujours on se base sur des
techniques françaises des travail mais
avec des produits beaucoup plus du sud
qu'il situait plutôt que de chercher un
poste de travail
je suis un bon resto il n'était pas loin
de mon école et il avait une étoile je
suis entre cuisine je fais la première
interview avec lui je me rappellerai
toujours elle était mon cou ne sommes
pas oui honte et sans main après on
descendait en cuisine et je lui une
autre réalité
je vais leur ordonnance équipe et il est
impeccable tous les services mais qui
balade et les plateaux alerte est pleuré
pendant quatre mois tout le soir mais
j'ai aussi à m'accrocher
[Musique]
ah c'est vrai qu'au départ c'était un
petit peu difficile il a fallu qu'ils
nous montrent un petit peu ce qu'ils
savaient faire qui prouve un petit peu
justement aux français et aux
versaillais surtout parce que c'est vrai
qu'on a quand même une clientèle
d'habitués puisque c'est vrai
qu'auparavant c'était aussi c'était
aussi les gens qui étaient beaucoup
habituel à la cuisine de monsieur zier
donc il est vrai que ces gens habitués
avec 7,7 restauration peu plus un petit
peu plus traditionnel
ces gens ont eu beaucoup de mal
physiquement il a fallu qu'il a vraiment
fallu qu'ils se démarquent et qui montre
justement la cuisine et sa son côté
créativité
bonjour ça va at il avait grand feu de
voiture bien ici comme common étrangers
un jeu tellement regardé dans tout le
monde surtout nuire l'habitude c'est les
français qui s'installe à l'étranger
et là ils ont vu en italia qui fait un
mètre soixante dix qui s'installe dans
un palace parisien et transilien
ile-de-france et scellés posés par un
souci mais ça lui pose est quand même s
il se posait beaucoup d'épaisseurs aux
audi mais qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
ici combien temps pour la prochaine
terminée
nos piètres la chaleur et la biométrie
habitants ailleurs le saviez à aimer les
noisettes ou vachement respecter les
clients fiona et les clients de konami
ghana chez nous ils dépenseront un
ticket moyen de 250 euros par personne
imaginez vous sortez d'un ajustement qui
vous paye être 400 euros et ça ça me
semble à moi ça me fout la trouille
parce que j'ai dit ah merde y'a
quelqu'un qui épate à venir manger chez
moi à dépenser aussi tant d'argent c'est
ça fait bien ça parce que cette vidéo on
se le dit qu'elles sont et ont fait
quelque chose de bien
en 2009 une audrey deux étoiles dont une
seule fois je serai en france je pense
que c'est la première je pense que c'est
la première fois que c'est arrivé et que
surtout en chef étranger a gagné 2
étoiles d'un coup dans en france
c'est à dire qu'elles sont autant vous
allez découvrir la conduite et rihanna
ont connu un peu sport en disant on y
arrive en quarts d'heure à la place d
une heure mais bon
[Musique]
bref salut tu va bien ça va bien une
fois sa pâte afin d'y voir un show
préparé un petit boost pour pour toi a
été gentil un gardien il s'est passé
quelque chose avant alors désolé pour
mes tard mais c'est dur de céréales
matin c'est fait les zones de l'est
c'est extraordinaire c'est quoi ça y est
les coûts et tico d'agneau de lait de
l'aveyron garde ça c'était facile à
utiliser ie pour 25 jours comme c'est
beau à ces magnifiques couleurs est
impoli tu vois qui est qui est donc très
jeunes vont donc se montre très clair
avec un foie gras de sucre et du grade à
turenne qui la font dans la cuisson les
produits c'est tout en fait si on n'a
pas un bon produit au départ on peut
jamais faire de la haute cuisine c'est
impossible
essayer de gagner un grand prix avec un
moteur pour y asseoir ou marcher grands
chefs bien non parce que ça devrait
bouger ça fait trois quarts d'heure qui
me disait roy il faut goûter saleya les
enfants bon appétit
chez toi tu c'est impressionnant ça mais
musculeux temps quand tu craques des
dents tu ajoutes a les joues qui sont
dans la viande
ça c'est du bonheur pourquoi sa balise
avec lui et donc bla bla bla bla et avec
son accent à couper au couteau qu'on
pourra tous maintenant ça va beaucoup
mieux mais avant ils sont mis à
l'italien pour me comprendre
[Musique]
menthe
on est un peu stressé là mais ça et je
me suis je me suis pris au jeu
tiens ça me stresse s'est pris au jeu un
peu forcément col amic analyser le
résultat secours ma merde on amer
[Musique]
alors évidemment on sourit on est
content d'être un parfait ce soit fini
tu vois où michel rencontres voilà on
est on est à la même place quoi donc ça
c'est important pour nous le reste après
avoir mal chalon ensemble quoi bon geste
au bon moment l'été reste en toile
la mort c'est parti c'est six et neuf
mois pour monter ce qui va pas tout une
veste à s'attaquer facilement là un peu
quand même mais attend il ya quelques
années comme moi touret quelques années
georges été choqués par ma femme ma
coiffure donc là petit à petit on essaie
d'argent je me rappelle pas de sare et
urrugne inconstant mais on n'est pas la
même musique
voici un bref et en bresse les meilleurs
boxeurs au dessus des 3 nominés
benoît bernard michel portos et philippe
labbé on a couronné un ces trois mondial
s'est jamais le même temps il y avait
cinq ans que j'ai commencé ce métier
les gens nous retrouver à la place les
gens que j'ai adoré admire et j'en passe
et des meilleurs merci moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fait il ya quelques années c'était juste
pas possible pour moi déjà la preuve
moi je pense pas
[Musique]
nominé cuisine d'année toi sinon je
pense qu'on approche à ne pas dans la
profession ou regarde plus comme à
benoît bernard le mec khady diop sont
voilà qu'on aille comprend 5
[Musique]
1h30
ça vaut le coup
il donne envie de cuisiner partage
vraiment son nom sonne comme un aimant
pour la cuisine c'est ça qui est bien
les noms de stars système là
on a à peine dans la cuisine on le sert
si ce n est une star pour la série de
lignes accès via la télé donc les stars
comme les ténors
c'est pas pourquoi
[Musique]
vous et pâtissiers les mecs la cuisine
la cuisine ça se goûte avant de faire
n'importe quoi
petit tartare rangés comme sa jolie
manque paraître moi je me sens cuisinier
plutôt qu'animateur puisque tous les
jours je suis dans ma cuisine je suis
pas tous les jeux sur un plateau télé a
pris ce que j'explique sais que mon
métier c'est cuisinier tout ce qui est à
côté ça reste à côté ou bien de la
cuisine mais nullement ça prend la place
de mon travail
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]